the Blackburn Shilling Gambit trap this
starts out similar to the legal trap of
e45 then F3 Knight C6 Bishop to C4 but
now black can play Knight to D4 now take
my material here on E5 if they do take
that material the queen can come to G5
now and if they are really scared about
this Pawn on G2 uh they could play G3
this Knight's going to fall if they see
that the knight's under attack they
could come down to F7 this bishop is
protecting the Knight so they could feel
that this is a safe square but
unfortunately for them it is not the
queen can now come to G2 attacking this
Rook now if they want to hold on to this
Rook they may play Rook to F1 but that's
going to lose to Queen to E4 check and
there's no real way to stop this